What's up guys, Jubilee team at Disneyland, thank you so much for watching. We love you guys so much!
We're about to go down this hill but in the meanwhile,
enjoy the episode!
(screaming)
see you next year
thanks for watching our videos
enjoy the video :)
What's your favorite alcohol, guys? Just tell us!
Hey, don't go on the internet saying this stuff! We're all underage!
Dr. Pepper!
We brought together seven teenagers. I'm a teenager. I'm a teenager. I am a teenager. I am a teenager. I'm a teenager
I am a teenager. I'm a teenager
One is a liar. If the group discovers who the liar is, they'll split a cash prize.
If the liar survives, they win the entire prize.
Are you guys all in college? No, I'm not.
Not right now. Where do you go? Passing City College. Where'd you go? I don't go to college. What are you doing?
Nothing, a lot of people expect like eighteen year old to go to college and move out.
I think it's very important to understand that there's still
People that are like my age or even older that still live with their parents.
How about music?
Like what kind of music do you guys like?
-I like Joji, Ariana Grande, Niki.
-like the Jonas Brothers.
-Ok. -I do like them, like the Jonas Brothers.
The Jonas Brothers are back!
-I went to their... -What classes are you guys taking in college?
I'm sorry but like, if we're all in college it'll be hard
Ah! OH SHIT!
I felt like I don't know she was trying a little bit too hard
She was wearing heels, I was like you are 26.
I just kind of went off of like my gut feeling.
Good luck guys!
Get the mole!
I think I was voted out because the way I present myself in the way I look, I look very mature and older.
Really quick, did any of you guys vote for Hillary Clinton in the last election? - I didn't vote I wasn't old enough
-I couldn't. -I wasn't old enough.
-Sorry, I just wanted to see if we could catch the mole. -I couldn't so...
-I was 16. Yeah. -I have a question. What do you guys like to do on your free time?
-I Skateboard. -I play the switch with my friends. -I love the switch.
-Yeah, I play like video games. -Yeah, I do. I have a YouTube channel
I do it with my mom actually, so that's really fun!
That's really cool!
I just finished Victorious.
-Yeah, Yeah. -I finished it in like...
-What's your favorite song?
- I want the phone
-OH LA boys.
-LA boys? -Really? -That's
-No, I like th song Take A Hint -Best friends brother
Take A Hint
I like when she counts
Oh Yeah!
Everyone knows about that
Did you guys see it on TikTok?
Get your hands up
Do you guys watch YouTube?
-Cause like... -Yeah
Not at all
I want your favourite...
-I watch YouTube. -You don't watch youtube?
-Are you lying? -I'm just kidding.
Okay, like my favourite is like David Dobrik.
Mr. Beast! Do you guys know who Mr. Beast is?
Yeah, Mr. Beast is cool
I don't really watch them actually
Okay, like who do you watch on YouTube? Oh like Miranda Sings some times.
Oh, nice nice.
I'm trying to think of something else.
I like food videos.
What's your favorite alcohol, guys? Just tell us!
Hey, don't go on the internet saying this stuff! We're all underage!
Dr. Pepper!
When did you guys promote from middle school?
Probably end of 2013
He was tall and then he had slippers and then so I was like, whew, you must be tired of being places.
I voted for him just 'cause he didn't speak a lot.
-Ooh. -What?!
Well, I'm obviously not an adult I don't know why you guys would think that but... I don't know what to say.
I like a lot of things young kids like...
like one direction.
Although they're not together anymore, they're really great. Um... a lot of kid shows. Um, yeah.
Yeah, I'm still a teenager. My room's messy as hell. My mom yells at me every day.
I spend my time talking to my girlfriend and playing video games, which one's more important. I don't know.
I'm still a teenager. I need to figure that one out.
I thought I'd make it to the end actually. I don't know why maybe because I think I look younger, but I don't know.
I think we can like talk about what's hard about being a teenager. So for me, it's like not having money
-Cause' you know at like our ages like 18-19. -Oh God. Why do you think I'm here.
I think if you're too loud you're compensating for something so
Bianca was definitely talkative.
18-19
-Like so at the stage where we're kind of adults but we're like still making minimum wage. -Yeah. -Yeah.
I don't know. I guess that's what kind of hard about being a teenager.
My source of money is like the (whispers) money
The what?
Is that all already
-Hey guys. -You don't get any.
My mom gives me money.
Really?
Yeah.
Allowance?
Yeah, it's embarrassing but yeah.
I mean, that's okay.
My mom doesn't give me money but I have a scholarship funded by Bill Gates, so thank you Bill.
When did you guys get credit cards? Like, what year?
-I got it last year. -I don't have one.
I got declined five times.
You got declined from...?
DON'T say it out loud
I think because my savings is under 200 and then I had to learn that five times and then um
Yeah, that's why I got I don't have a credit card right now at the moment.
Oh quote your favorite favorite vine.
uhh
oh my gosh, hold on hold on
David is like what?
Oh my god. I know that one. He's after chicken
That was hilarious!
-Oh my God, oh my God. -Okay. The one we're like the guys in the grocery store and then somebody throw something at me. He's like b-
I don't wanna cuss/
Do you remember the rat one where he's like hizzuk--
I was gonna say that one.
Ooh, when'd you get Twitter?
Are you guys..wait
Are you guys like... Are you guys politically active?
Do you know who your senator is since you're from California?
Wait umm I know...
There's so much happening!
I see something about Andrew Yang and someone's like don't vote for him. I was like, ok!
For president?
Yeah, but do you know who your senator is?
Wait.
Arnold Schwarzenegger?
What?!
I'm just wondering.
-I know my stance. -Yeah
Because maybe like, the senator is...
Bruh
You're cool man, he was like the easy person to vote out. I thought everybody else was gonna vote him out. So I just did
(Everyone raises their hands)
Let's do it. Just in case.
Should we talk about slang like, teenage slang?
Or what about like dance trends?
-Slatt! -Slatt!
Okay, yeah! do you guys know what like what stanky leg is?
if so do it now
Yeah
I can't do it
You're just trying to pick something.
I wanna see if you know what it is
Alright do it.
Do it I'll do it with you.
oh it's gonna be on the Internet
you got it
Look at this.
Okay, that's a new thing.
That's like last year.
-Like this. -Let's go if your brother knows what that is.
I can do this but that's like
Who was the most popular rapper when you were in like elementary school,
Soulja Boy
6789998212~
Do you guys listen to Sean Kingston?
-Yeah. -Sean...
Beatiful girls~
Off course!
Fire burning fire~
Ay yeah!
Most serious question ever, Spotify or Apple Music?
Apple music!
spotify!
oh man
I'm sorry.
Tear!
I didn't want to talk that much but I also I thought that sometimes people were talking too much about the wrong things
That wouldn't lead us to figuring out who the mole was. So I just wanted to change the subject
Which okay, probably got me voted out, but whatever I guess
Ohhh!
It's you
Not me.
I trusted him.
Who is it?
I'm 18 years of age guys!
Cool cool cool cool cool
I voted for you. I knew it.
That's cool.
How old are you?
She's thirty.
Can you guess?
21!
I'm 25.
What!
A lot of the TV shows they mentioned were
part of my childhood as well. I just shifted the timeline.
She was not on my radar at all.
Just the answers she was giving like it just seemed like they flowed perfectly.
You know what's funny? I voted for Branden three times, right?
He's giving me a ride home. So that's cool.
I thought a lot of people were the mole actually.
No.
I would have never guessed it was Kasey for sure. Yeah. She was really good
Don't trust anybody out here, you know, I can't trust nobody. I can't trust you. You look-- are you a teenager?
Really?!
I can't trust you. Thanks for watching. I really appreciate...
Did your change slides?
Okay, that's fine. Anyway, Adrian ruined it, but thanks for watching. Bye
Alright, let's do another one!